[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome my name is Rob this is Jake we
are playing a game called next machina
yeah yeah uh we're really excited to
play this and I had just played an hour
Jake and uh Jake you've been basically
demanding I've never had you demand that
we play a game and I found that very
intimidating and having again just
played an hour I'm I'm pretty much sold
on this game it's really fun to play
yeah yeah twin-stick kind of shoot them
up copy down right it's by the people
who did a house mark or the people at
house mark and those of you who played a
resogun will probably be familiar with
this with them mm-hmm but I'm just gonna
get right into it we're gonna do a
roundel we basically just a guy hiding
back here I can't get them didn't get
them Wow he's uneasy right Hasani I
trust you are much better than um yeah
the plan is we're gonna we're gonna play
uneasy just to kind of show the game as
well as try to get through it this is a
beta bill yeah obviously on top left
there we're trying to get through as
much as possible to show you guys what
this upcoming game has to offer
um I'll be bumping the music to every
now the music is a highlight i I can't a
lot of vibe from like I don't know like
a deaf hug strong album set like heavy
techno high bpm
definitely gets you going mm-hmm I
actually hey I went to the settings I'm
making through that later just to show
how awesome the sound is so I'm using
yeah you can turn up the music obviously
because it's just it's such a driving
part of this game yeah for sure takes a
lot of times too yeah and it's like a
resogun in that you are saving humans
again it's kind of like a little touch
that they have in a lot of their games
like deaf deaf puns Trung says Aurora
what deaf comes out of that pocket the
artist did the music for Tron's and
legacy yeah yeah yeah this is all right
just alright the the album itself is
pretty awesome I think yeah but yeah
I've give you questions in the chat here
put them in there and I'll relay them to
Jake so I think you you know a pretty
good amount about this game I played um
I played a decent amount of it doesn't
have to play 17 hours to beta but I
don't think that's right
but I did play a lot of it both through
this beta and then I played it at PSX a
while ago and I that's right like
essentially fell in love with it
yeah damn see this is the area that I
always died out Oh your tell me about
this so the enemy types are really
interesting cuz they like I feel like
every stage you may be introduced to a
new enemy but more or less you know it's
like the combination of different types
of enemies will like kind of disable
your your comfortability factor which is
nice like you're constantly like
changing up how you yeah get away from
enemies and your strategy as a whole
which is we'll definitely see that we
get to the boss - like as you can see
right now I'm kind of like flying all
over the place with the boss you have to
be a little bit more careful at how you
get around so I got question um so in
each little stage here you have like
humans that you can safe and they're
they're kind of being I guess I don't
know if they're being killed or like
sucked into the cyber world by these
enemies so you have a limited amount of
time to get to them if you get them all
does it seems like you get a maybe a
bonus weapon or is it just score score
bonus so see the multiplier up there it
just Adam over here okay the multi-cut a
cig multiplayer well no a simulation
look like fire but there's also a lot of
hidden humans that I write completely
found and I remember when I played this
at PSX the developers are showing me
that if you save a certain human you can
go an alternate path through this level
I did it there but I for the life we
don't remember how I did it so I had
accidentally saw like a alternate exit
yeah but I don't I didn't know how to
access it or how to
you can see it and I'm not sure how idea
how I did that questions of the chat how
much will this this game be on release
I'm not sure and laughs they've not
announced that okay um they haven't
announced the release date early but it
is coming that it is coming soon I guess
number 60 oh yeah sure
that's pretty safe uh how much was Reza
was that 20 bucks in that came out it's
a good question it it'll probably be
around the same as resogun or alienation
cuz it's both both games by them and
it's available for both PC and ps4 ps4
yeah but interestingly enough this is
the first how smart game at least I
think it's the first the first in a
while that isn't being published by Sony
okay so that means that it might come
somewhere else but I we I don't have no
idea I don't know something you guys
don't but it will be ps4 and Xbox one
definitely if you like smash TV and
resogun and this kind of Arkady Action
shooters then yeah oh we look at food
started up it was like right here I like
did something it was like alternate exit
I don't know
you said Xbox one - no no I say Xbox one
you may have just just be a CPC and ps4
yeah just PC ps4
but yeah this it's a fun game so to
Reiner saying tutors there's not really
any type of progression which which is
interesting like as I like that was a
little bummed I mean I don't know if
there are plans to have any kind of
progression system thing I read
somewhere that I don't know alienation
but I guess that also did not have any
kind of permission so alienation was
different in that it was more of a hoop
shooter it was kind of Diablo is like a
light Diablo I guess you could say oh
this is neat when a change of the
perspective here yeah I do like this
little section here but I think with
resogun it didn't really have
progression either but you can unlock
different ships and we want to save this
human God you can unlock different ships
and things like that so I don't know if
you'll be able to change character or
get different you can't get different
weapons but I don't know that remains to
be seen
obviously this is a beta that's right
and God YouTube user in the chat star as
in the symbol his name says will just be
pull off like resogun and I believe it
is confirm they have it they had a
trailer out give the trailer out they
had a trailer I've been saying it that
it was going to have local co-op this
okay that is I not confirmed I don't I
don't know from what I heard it sounded
like they're just focusing on
single-player okay
his first boss wasn't too bad you
finally hear his feet wonder if he had
that sound effect the whole time or was
just cuz just a chaos of like shooting
music and I was just dead quiet now
I was liked how because when I played
this at PSX we only played that first
area and then when the beta come out you
got I think there's two there's another
area after this but it definitely
changes up the setting quite a bit so
far as like different weapon types - I
mean you can upgrade your weapon
obviously to have more projectiles but
if the other ones were like a sword I
saw I do those drop randomly yeah okay
so my special ability right now or my
bat it's a rock oh it's just a rock like
me and you lose it all everything you
had you lose when you die sometimes you
can you'll drop things when you die and
you can go and pick them up however and
I think I think it changes on difficulty
to a local co-op was confirmed today
okay okay that is good then cuz local
co-op sounds like it would be a lot of
fun yeah really I think they showed a
little bit other actually it's it was it
was interesting cuz there's one map that
I saw here where like some of these maps
are very symmetrical and it actually
makes sense for like you both could
branch off on different planes kind of
Oh that'd be really cool yeah your man
get rid of this thing
okay good I got it
launch date revealed to be June 20th
cool so we knew that I just took over
alive to say I don't know there's the
trailer yes I'm like a that's right I
forget if you told me that was uh under
a Niigata NDA but yeah I looked it up
and I saw a trailer so I don't know
there you have it those guys are tough
these blending what the one just took
founded like they stack up which is cool
because the other the previous house
marks in how smart games usually their
co-op came after in their mocha flaking
rule after launch but that's kind of
cool that we're getting it day one yeah
but man you don't need Cola I mean I
mean co-op is a great addition but like
I see I'm so freakin and it's like it's
it's it's hypnotizing right it's like
once the music's going once you're like
in a rhythm I love how you can swoop the
humans right out of those guys hand
right like you don't necessarily film
where they do they're like digitizing
them or something
oh yeah at some point you should pause
and this is here this music yeah I had
to do it I was like no I need I need it
we can't talk about like rhythm games
like thumper earlier it's like yeah it's
very hypnotizing I think it's certainly
the case here where the feet is just
just powers you could yeah you get
different types of weapons obviously use
your primary one you're seeing here and
there's a shield rocket launcher rocket
launcher I've seen rocket launcher I've
she's like a charged up laser type that
everything is sweet it's my favorite
because you can you know obviously shoot
through entire lines of enemies swarms
and that's pretty useful when you're
trying to like basically you're
constantly trying to manage an exit
right like an exit strategy and it gets
chaotic like there's such close calls
right we're like you barely get through
you thicket it it's a sense of sense of
feeling up like a badass just barely
getting out all these things are deadly
too when they start leaving trails oh my
god
yeah those trails are rough cuz you like
what you're saying I could just throw
off your entire exit energy I also like
how each stage like you lose a sense of
direction of where you're going you know
what I mean I kind of like that word
you'll just be like it's like that you
you're like on a giant cube then you
never know where exactly you are you
just get like fling up flung around it's
like a nice uneasy feeling I don't know
how to say it's like you just you just
barely feel like you're getting through
but yeah this is definitely like I'm
gonna I'm excited to see the scores
people managed to get on this like
resogun was insane seeing some of those
scores and once again like I forget what
my record is on the beta but but like it
seems huge and I look at the Hornets
like oh never mind
yeah all these things
yeah that's better there are some stages
to they're really playing looks like
this is pretty easy like I don't know
and then they just throw everything at
you like that one rose the perspective
from behind yeah they're just like you
killed two things and move on it's like
all right right right right right
I can't get to that yet actually I think
this was an area I have difficulty with
did you go get a human over here and
then you can get like trap the trap yeah
so you have a - looks like you can get
like triple - yes we've got about three
you have to weigh from the recharge
is their online co-op I think it's just
local co-op yeah that I that I don't
know that like they didn't give us
insider info hon either so I'm not I'm
not sure I know I do not leave in the
Haun's getting or will be available on
the Vita
ah damn yeah I don't I don't I don't
think the Vita could handle this game at
least as it is now because even with
resogun they had to make some
significant changes but I know they had
the downscale it a little bit for that
order run it there's all those boxes
right the voxels were just such a cool
style here he had simply a style they've
kind of owns to over this generation
wasn't an alienation but get what their
other game is that they're working on
what's called hit runner
but that game seems real it seems to
have a similar boxing style
it's like wait wait what whenever that
happens I'm just like wait where am I
now that's cool
yeah this would be a hard game to run on
the Vita yeah let's switch the switch
you never know if you're watching how
Smart Switch oh my god on swish I would
I would never leave my house alright we
are about to fight did you end up
fighting getting this boss this is oh
this will talk about the music the VP
I'm just changes oh my god song is so
sick okey posit in turn turn up music I
have to hear it now I this is where I
went okay I'm done I guess I just wanted
to go stream it now yeah let's go oh all
the way fine do it oh that's good that's
good you're good yeah
Oh is the boss
little assault against this guy that
sucks
that it and I really
[Music]
[Music]
almost reminds me of justice to the
music yeah you know justice Stella
I have seen those like I like more
darker like electronic yeah that's
pretty but dad deadly
why you can turn the app I'm digging the
music cool me too
yeah damn this is uh oh
[Music]
Oh God
[Music]
who did it nice
world complete all right I was gonna ask
you do you know how many world so I
haven't been past three so there could
be more or a good end there I don't know
though because people got some really
high scores for having only three but
also people are some people are really
good at these kind of games probably
going to find out at well actually we
probably won't make a pass this that I
have no lives left and I haven't gotten
a lot in a long time I kept if you if
you lose a life what happens I'm sorry
if you lose all your lives what happened
you get to continue but it's usually I
don't like continuing because you lose
like you lose your multiplier and I I
think your points starts over too so
it's like yeah what's the point makes
sense right but yeah it's like I'd
rather just start over and how many
levels does this game have we're not
sure yet I think if it three world so
this is a third world for sure once
again this is the beta though there
could be more there could be less no
there could be less because it's out
three but there could be more wow this
thing is all those are new these are
like kind of crap type menus
saebom oh I got two lives yes you should
uh like turn some of that on cuz it's
kind of weird
it is a little weird not to have some
sound effects we won't have it 160 per
face that's Oh God whoa shields I want
that
[Music]
II
oh that's the saving the humans is like
that's what gets me killed every single
time it's funny because we were playing
zombies this week and it reminds me very
much like getting up trying to get a
perk oh I lost the human
I'll get him getting it doesn't right
nice ooh
snag the human to justify so when you
kill all the enemies you get sent to the
next page do you like as you were
telling me you're trying to get high
score is this something that you maybe
would save the last guy and try to like
break up any like you see cancers in the
corners and stuff like you try to get
all that stuff yeah I've done it before
oh I don't know if I'm gonna survive
past this oh I killed it um oh I lost
that human rip see what I mean like you
like yeah I would want to save the last
enemy I guess I don't know I think
you're right I mean I think it's
definitely you
wouldn't be a bad idea except I like
they're so easy to kill and it's just
like you know like kind of just kind of
burn through them beginning that I kind
of get hypnotized you just keep going
Evan F says I think I'm getting too old
for these [ __ ] cases you can't
keep up so I'm looking at it yeah yeah
like you're saying exactly thing I was a
psycho keep on oh you yeah I mean
looking at it is I think it's a lot
different than playing it right because
I when I saw people playing this game in
front of me at PSX I was like oh right I
know if I can do this but when I
actually got my hands on it like it
feels so good and it's so responsive
that they write that it you kind of like
once you get into the rhythm it doesn't
it doesn't seem as overwhelming as it
may right yeah the controls are so
responsive and it is not like you try to
juggle a ton of different mechanics it's
just shoot - and special a friggin sword
[Music]
oh no I only got the single home blast
gun or whatever
actually to looking at that the Oh
looking at that clock over there - I
wonder if slowing down dam owner of
slowing down would affect your score at
the end
[Music]
don't continue succumb to the power the
machine overlords I like it
yeah the trailer there's a little bit of
it like the art they had it so quo owner
those opened up with it
those are lock for me they were arena
and single world yeah huh
I want to see rankings
I'm number 20 hell yeah 20 out of 128
all right at least them on a higher part
but I'll endure some of these scores 177
million when you're at I'm I got 22
million that's not easy
that's uneasy and I get normal 331
million so we're gonna do normal now
though do you want to do the first
normal run sure I would love to play
awesome maybe we'll try hard to at some
point but hard it's hard yeah it really
is central sick
so there's a dude hiding back there he's
tough to get to because right we're in
the last area it's too late oh he's
tough to get to because there's only
like four enemies you come so quickly
and I've also noticed there's those
green little beetle things that yeah
occasionally pop up I am Not sure those
do I think you should get extra points
yeah I think it's just like another
thing to collect yeah but if you die
they disappear so like in normal so an
easy one all guide really yeah so uneasy
when you die it doesn't reset the stage
what we just got hit it doesn't reset
the stage you just pick up right from
the left off but if you die a normal
it'll reset the stage you're on and if
you die on normal and they disappear so
you want to make sure to get that if you
get that you wanna keep that that way
what's that thing that's oh there's one
of them Krystal is it to kill the woman
oh what if I had something like spawned
on you
uh-oh this is nah
in the chat someone I can't read it he
says there's a hard jeez yeah yeah get
it gets it gets really tough it's
definitely not for the faint apart
oh my god Wow let's see like right there
is this like insane oh they announced
today what did they say it was June 20th
it was supposed to come out or June June
19 I don't remember but they don't June
20th June 20th yeah well I get to UM I
think how you get smashed up dang it so
yeah see now resets this Oh Ruth see
that guy can't even get some owner who
just have to like burn through enough
enemies and then they open up yeah it
generally happens right
[ __ ]
this is also different area looks like
you found a yeah that's why wasn't say I
did not play this but how did yeah how
did you I have no idea how I got you
I like yeah I no idea so yeah this was
the area that they that secret area for
MU not secret just alternate path yeah
maybe these things were paying the ass
to I remember yeah oh no you got trapped
ah all right
I did it a long time what's power shot
oh that's act the one we like here yeah
nice I thought you're gonna miss me yeah
yeah this is the best time don't one
shot left with yourself oh there's all
right no maybe I thought you're good I
thought you have it consistently right
there's operates on a pulldown all your
specials
maybe not I think you're good yeah you
for I don't know what I was looking
oh you lost oh I'm moving them inside
game
what uh Nobles harder
yeah so they totally are random sort I'm
not a big fan oh yeah the sort I don't
really like because you spend so much
time trying to keep the weapon up that's
my favorite because it's three just like
a shotgun right nice
damn
this part this is the part that I always
that leave deities once a specially on
one wall
man I know how I got they stole it right
from him he's not happy
oh [ __ ]
uh he's losing a human whatever take
them
[Music]
so mate I think it's maybe it's
environmental like you can like get in
here right if I blow that up now yeah
there are certain ones you can break and
other ones you can't
nice oh no you didn't get a big bit
different so the other one I'll have
stolen yet those things scare me on fire
yeah we're there's no one of those
beetles can't go lows
I want em Oh barely God
[Music]
nice
Oh - I don't - enough
I always forget yeah - is helpful you
have to like you definitely can't rely
too much on it because it will it
doesn't either like recharge and the
worst is being trapped with no - yeah
man oh so I try to take that thing out
right windows open up right does that
thing will ruin here
nice stay go that should be much easy to
deal with now and there's a ton of [ __ ]
down
who is getting sticky though a little
bit checking to see if isn't haha what
this thing over here the thing I know I
thought like a qualifying I can't
seriously
yeah we are
[Music]
so again is there any you get drops more
awesome if you have like a high
multiplier or something I don't think so
so I I know he drops a random but there
are certain enemies that if you kill the
whole group of them they will drop one
for sure
they're usually you know the ones that
like follow up half in a line yeah if
you kill all of them you get it dropped
for sure
[Music]
gab you look so cool now
it's just
so epic like you can feel like you're
saving the world oh yeah nice nice no so
this is you're gonna want to - for sure
through these things
oh that's really neat those things are
tough to kill though oh yeah I got
killing cheese
oh you might get all three beetles on a
103 oh maybe because you've died sucking
all right boss time uh-oh well I fall I
fell the music change
No Mas
what kind of hiding in the corner shield
grab that
got the shield though look who it is
the Fein Tron suck it some sort no no
you don't sweetie so can I switch
weapons I don't think so my hat look you
look on Oh
so I think I think they're for different
things I could be wrong though but if
you look on the left there they're all
there so cuz that one's shield get my
hand
that one's haha so that one's your
rocket now your Rockets ready again
that one's shield I think that one's
when you drop a explosion when you -
that's triple - yeah I think I think I
can switch weapons right I don't think
so is there an alert yeah we've got an
Amber Alert huh yeah what phone just
went off wait that's my car
alright I want you to say 2 million
that's pretty good thanks
[Music]
this gets a little this gets a little
tougher on medium though oh damn it yeah
these guys are they don't mess around
those like ball turrets yeah it looks so
cool when they go underground like yeah
they like pull up the voxels
Oh No ooh barely swooped them
I don't like thats so satisfying just
like they're about to taking you to
swing yeah right alum oh I'm trying to
hold on yeah so that is kind of weird it
looks like you should be able to stand
there so it's enemy Tai Chi kill more
enemies right Oh My yes once you kill
that suno look what all right
[Music]
uh what's up Jaden
no that's AXA do it alright warm enough
still so the enemies I was talking about
that come in a line I think there should
be some coming this way at some point oh
yeah see there they are right there but
I focus on so they got away but if you
killed them you're scaring oh damn
weapon up that'll help
that's going to help
[Music]
ah I supposed to do I remember this part
this part I definitely was yelling
myself at oh my god how do I do it it ah
ok I just get out of there
Jaden s1 is the Zelda scream uh not
anytime soon I mean whenever we get the
whatever the DLC comes out that's a
that's a definite Triforce scream yeah
they have that they're adding that like
survival mode right yeah it's good work
to keep saying it's probably gonna drop
during e3 but about whatever Nintendo
Direct they have
I wonder if shooting that machine right
there above you or if that is what oh no
you can't even get to it oh come down
you can though yeah up and down here oh
oh and the only right man is a human
there too
you got him well it's minigames
successful I wonder what he did that
chief what did you discover I broke the
game or fixed the game I don't know Oh
hello
oh my god Oh it'll get you yeah
oh it looks like to your multiplier goes
down by one when you are something you'd
I didn't realize that
I hate those things hate all these
things that is definitely like a goal
you really want to seek out these
turrets oh man yeah usually like right
when I get to an area the first thing I
do is try to take out this - especially
the ones that just like like these that
just like lay down things to block your
path yeah but it's hard to write because
there they are wrecking you hi Manny
how's it going I've just green anyone I
see you since I Oh
coming in the third
come mr. heavy suicide hi boom so here
you have to destroy those turrets in
order to get off this area Oh get out of
there
wait what Oh God there we go
to make them
[Music]
oh that's a cool one I like AoE yeah
over there horns yeah these things are
nice things deadly with you that's your
R trigger button right yeah there's also
a - explosion and get out of there
I love it thank you oh really say that
yeah oh no it's too much going on when
you grab on your head thank you yeah Sam
it boo shield though I don't really like
any of this is a lot going on extra life
extra live while we're up there I'll
shoot it alright nice Oh
Dido
yeah you're right they do say thank you
I think it's the same thank you in
residence yeah I think in beds are than
they do that to you know I'm afraid
rather than in a very long time
oh you got a human I want a human combo
nice moving right along here yeah
oh this is all I hate the strongest
yep I hate this one
that that shield is pretty nifty yeah it
is ah rats
oh that was so dumb why I don't even
kill you it was a turret I just won
right Oh at least you picked up the
weapon up yeah
if you ride the weapon up is it's huge
when I keep something here
so you will so if you die
you will start over to get better score
I usually do I don't do can because if
you notice your score resets yeah when
you continue so yeah when I when I die
just restart but I probably shouldn't I
should probably like follow it to the
end so I know at least the debate at the
end of this beta because like I said
I've never made it to the third boss
because I yeah because I did the first
time I did it on the easy just to get a
feel for it and then I only did normal
and I only made it to the second boss
without getting anything you I made it
to the third area but not circles thank
you oh thank you thank you God
leave them alone
[Music]
ah it'd be cool like all the humans you
didn't save I come back in life assemble
like a boss like you maybe they help you
on the final boss assemble like a yeah
fight for you for all the people you're
saying
it's nice one more oh god no they are
you got nowhere to go
how many levels you're on twelve so I
think it's I think I don't remember how
many but I'm you're close to the boss oh
my god I hit her all right
[ __ ]
[Music]
Oh human human soul it looks like says
what's supposed to release May 23rd and
they delayed in a month yeah I
my guess is because they wanted to get a
cash pop in at launch I don't know
though it sucks oh man
oh it's those tails whose damn tails
alright just taking too long isn't it
let's do this
I'm also not killing them I keep
realizing it
kind of key ah
[Music]
[Music]
you're trapped oh no you're good
god I hate those tail alright you did it
though
I should take out those turrets
otherwise they're gonna get ya and it
also makes it easier oh my god two more
just poppin
I was looking at chat very nice comment
in there
awesome thank you guys for stopping by
and watching this concealed hat for how
I have a really hard time reading chat
especially while playing a game like
this I mean I I can't read the names
like I need to like get into the yeah I
play barefoot air taste ball yeah
that's why I probably mess up names
oh this is where okay oh I gotta hear
this be change
oh you saw these right uh hon so oh yeah
that's cool see here oh these oh whoa I
did not see that yeah darker edgier it's
too dark
yeah well maybe we could take off the
let's try this one but also I need to
hear this music because BPM change
yeah
Kratos whoever points out that been next
or that a house mark never actually gave
a release day that's the Sony store has
placeholder IV that's right does it
sound like when I was talking and it
sounded like when they were announcing
those leases and sound like it was into
play it just sounded like they were
finally register now because I know they
held off a long time they're just saying
summer also this darker grittier filter
really fits the music yeah I guess it
looks I can't really tell
I'm more concerned about staying alive
Keisha
man and getting stuck with the sword yes
ah you know I was about to say though
the shorts kind of good for these
situations oh yeah you can knock those
into it yeah like I don't know it's a
pretty decent like melee up Oh got you
excited to melee yeah he's very DK
inspired oh my god a porno in hero's
name is was named yet econ realize that
dropping bail
I don't have a special now
probably should be shooting him
yeah I wasn't reading the barrels
because they seemed to take effect by
the time I destroyed them they were
already like not an issue anymore yeah
like I - step past them someone asks is
this final code this is not final code
this is you closed beta it is actually
closed now so you can't play it but they
let us uh continue a little bit longer
just we could do this stream hopefully
we'll get final code soonish go yeah but
yes this is still beta they said we
might run into some issue since the beta
isn't supported anymore since they're
working on the final build but so far I
haven't run in any issues I think the
only issue I ran into was when it first
came out or when I first entered the
beta I lost music after the first Oh No
after the first area and I was like I
wonder if it's just cuz it's a beta and
then I quit came back couple hours later
and it was there on earth has been an
issue since yeah that would have been
really disappointing yeah
oh no oh you some another wife he'll be
fine
ah
nice
I mean I'm not Don I mean I'm not dying
for a narrative where I could have story
but I'd like to know maybe who this
character is gob nice requests are
especially those cutscenes to the
cutscenes oh man if there's more of that
I will be so excited Jesus yeah this
this one gets did you get to this lawyer
no never never been there spike it's a
lot harder man it's not even starting if
any live side then he's gone state to
continue also these like enemy types are
different they like LAN genuine I feel
like
I haven't played I don't really know
resogun that well but someone is asking
like difficulty compared to resogun oh
[ __ ] um I think I think I think it's
about the same I'd say because I'm
pretty sure hard-on here is probably
about as hard as it is on resogun but I
don't entirely remember like I said it's
been a while since I played resogun oh
we should definitely see how hard I'm
hard you want to do uh maybe like one or
two more continues and we can switch the
hard smart-bomb oh [ __ ]
it's smart-bomb that yeah okay it's that
everybody yeah but would you ask if you
want to keep on you want to do like one
or two more continues and then give Hart
a try yeah I think you know how much
time do I have
anyways oh we haven't got an hour yeah
little Anthony I'll store that guy yeah
there's kind of hiding in the lava there
whoopsie
oh you go you got him nice what that guy
jumps
oh nice swoop them just in time funny
a human soul so they added alienation
shooting in combat style game fry put in
a more compact space yes it also doesn't
have the whole loop grind thing and it's
it's not as complex in terms of
mechanics like you don't have a primary
weapon a secondary grenades it's just
you've got one stick to shoot and then
you've got R which is your special
ability a lot of humans dead though Rob
well yeah it's this thing right here
yeah there you go
no uh-uh man that's cruel you have to
kill that thing before you can get to
the human right okay yes you can only
hold one weapon at a time this is -
explosion that's your shield that's
triple one and that's your weapon your
secondary weapon I can't drop any of
them or like well you can not pick
something up I guess you could not pick
what if you noticed uh when a weapon
thing drops it changes so you can pick
it up like it'll go from rocket launcher
the sword - to smart bomb or whatever
and you can pick it up when you want wow
there's a lot think you can handle that
yes you did and you got a smart bomb too
oh no oh well
oh I didn't see him
oh my god oh you dick that's okay that's
okay
focus nice
whoa
all right last one
but I mean I know might as well try make
it to the boss I mean we're not gonna
last long in hard anyway good point yeah
we just keep going yeah I mean yeah good
boy we'll really only probably try hard
for like five minutes and I haven't seen
the boss do this I kinda want to see the
ball he said okay let's do it
yeah the bosses have been pretty cool
looking
I don't care hey gum
[ __ ] damn I'm not that bad
plus it's like what your second time
playing oh yeah and how I'm just is not
what hour and a half planes yeah screams
as I played 17 hours I don't think
that's right but I definitely did play
this good amount I think I left it on
over at work overnight oh yeah that can
happen once a while
[Music]
cross-references kind of weird to see
next machina has a local cooperate from
the get-go but seemingly no online co-op
and resogun an alienation at online club
since day one and patched in local cost
yeah that's a good point no I don't want
to lose this Oh
that whip thing you gotta get rid of
that whip thing Hey oh you're right like
that can you even know I don't even you
can at least not yet it looks like it's
covered by cubes we've got a shield Oh
that'll help oh yeah what's you up oh my
god no I didn't mind if I try this yes
you can
plus you're better than mean zero I
haven't made it her own so you're on the
chat in hate tween so he hates you What
did he say it says always suck oh [ __ ] I
didn't continue in time oh no [ __ ] well
go to go to menu you can pick the world
oh you're right single world okay host
they're only three which one are you
sure do they unlock as we go on maybe
should I just do normal here instead of
doing hard and see we can get to the
boss or should we just start from the
beginning with hard uh I don't know you
guys won't see hard right away or should
we get to the boss if we do hard I think
we should do normal you can or mahoma
here yeah well we'll get to hard after
we beat the third boss we'll get to okay
hard yeah like I said I don't think
we'll last lean hard anyway
Oh God well I'll do a good start
laughter women oh well
Oh
here to this guy
we're driving both of my dad
[Music]
I'll bangin
oh wow well I like how they change up
that enemy type right where it lunges
like yeah it's not a consistent speed
right you like you have to account
predict it's like quick jump on you oh
[ __ ]
yeah
I was another interesting interesting
thing you don't have to destroy the
cannons to go to the turret in this area
you could store the mobile and all gonna
lose amar
yeah it's just tough oh nice
yeah I get to the other one who's gonna
weapon up to where left left left
this parts tricky
Thanks
oh they're hiding in there
[Music]
Wow yikes
[Music]
again my shield
[Music]
what was that noise power shots so good
[Music]
I think I think the sword needs maybe
like a longer reach yeah that would be
good like the well they call the smart
bomb is good because you can obviously
like create a hole like you any you want
you want all your specialists to like
offer some sort of exit
just Akula says you have to - when the
circle is within the other circle I
missing something I'm Matt or like
around your guy
I'll get the shield below you
Oh Mike this one is tough yeah but you
got this
I agree zero great music oh nice
[Music]
let's leave
bringing turrets
Oh human human
[Music]
oh did I get that you have a guy fastest
right yeah we made it to I don't
remember what stage it was but I'm
little more again through these faster
than I am great it's quite all right
Oh
yeah I'm doing this part mm-hmm
Oh
[Music]
oh dang Oh got the shield lost in you oh
you got this
can you imagine if there was friendly
fire on no human would ever survive kill
them all
well I got that thing oh gosh there's so
many of them there we go I was tough
this is where we got yeah we definitely
got here but it's good yeah as really it
is the same des devs made resogun could
have some when I dash through that yeah
the weapon I think you were saying it
like took me a while to realize but yeah
but the weapon upgrades our weapon up
sort of my columns are definitely
crucial yeah because you don't need to
focus as much on aiming as you just
focus on moving the connection yep yep
nice oh I made it nice
it's like more and more hectic this is
what bought twelve levels
14
yeah
oh I sorted I sorted
[Music]
[Music]
oh oh damn immediately kind of deal with
this dumb thing Oh
[Music]
jail the tougher got dis oh maybe not
we're gonna chat you got it
oh my god
imagine doing this in real life I would
have not made it past one one oh those
things will get you really what are you
hitting I don't know
response that thing goes it like saw
they dine they zip and I shoot him and I
wait because I'm trying to shoot out of
there oh damn 0z he is on point
and then he corrected and he says was
get back on point
oh my gosh look it's the dumb frickin
wheels
I'll hit me again
hey-ya
get out hey Jessica Wynn says you should
not care about the humans he's right
yeah maybe at this point
Oh what
[Music]
well one human dead
those dirty Legos chair yeah other
shirts ah well doing one more or more
continuing and one more Pistons but
we'll go to continue just so we don't
have to like switch on the fly
oh sure oh I think this is it this is
the run
that's not
no this is it okay - though you have a
good turrets yep yep hey cuz once or it
dealt with
Oh boat turret so this guy's Costantini
whatever
destroy that turret there it is
alright don't choke easy easy no problem
come on throw something harder at me
alright just kidding
Oh God just shooting go home oh my god
oh yes smart bomb that's it is so clutch
I didn't have some oh he's my rocket
launcher oh is that we take them or got
a nice oh we get it all oh oh oh whoa
this is interesting that's new this is
the boss I don't care about humans right
now I got Indiana Jones in my way yeah
damn whoa hold on reset yeah it does
pretty neat this is cool yeah oh God
look stop hey you got it keep going
[Music]
or have to kill this thing all night to
move on
Wow
got shield plus
[Music]
alright I'll give it one more continue
and then let you uh if you fare better
on this I know there's gonna mess up
you're putting me hey I don't want yeah
I don't want to do this oh you guys
though I didn't kill it in time it's
like I got it I got a speed 3ds if only
you had like I don't know you know like
a dope weapon or special rock well I had
a rock and when I died
what happened
that humans need to get a happy then
[ __ ]
man gonna try good luck thanks
[Music]
weapon up there you go that'll help now
you just got to deal with that thing
quick
oh yeah through clothes a nice fat human
what laughs ed
I was there
you
no but now 100 it stops okay
damn oh it's so close that's good
oh that's a floor falling apart - I
don't know I wouldn't be surprised after
that Raiders of the Lost Ark stage yeah
right oh [ __ ]
[Music]
what's up I don't know how you think I
don't know how I
just barely threaded through the gap
what is that oh my heart's needle-like
get out of here
deal with that thing yeah geez that does
that block nothing
zero says GG thanks
holy God this game is insane
yeah God so like this one aims up the
difficulty a lot right like the second
stage is is tougher than the first but
this one's like [ __ ] yeah Wow
I mean Chevy should be focusing on the I
don't know I'd shoot those turrets but
the problem is this yeah yeah take them
out I always forget about that you only
mean like you're like you get so caught
up and shooting like the mass amount of
enemies yeah forget about like oh we're
just kind of weird right cuz if you like
the most good actually not Huntress hey
I was I was gonna say like I feel most
games I tend to focus on smaller guys
first anyway that's with you guys but I
guess that kind of depends from game
yeah but like and this is definitely
it's good to try to get those turrets
first unless you're being overwhelmed
and watch out don't get to just get the
F out all these guys get out of the way
I'm trying to get something oh oh I lost
it
can you boost into enemies and kill them
like in reso run I don't know I don't
want to try oh you got a deal with these
things
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not that bad I know I know you're
not bad zero oh great
[Music]
Oh now we get to accident Co we look
like a badass
okay boss I think there's 15 oh damn -
song is awesome yeah I was waiting for
that I have addiction I was just walking
I was just bathroom and like rank it up
on that on the board I went to the
bathroom after I played that hour and
was like nodding as I was a cereal okay
shit's like still in my head
[Music]
music Brad
well
this is uh not gonna be easy
you have not seen this boss I've not
seen this boss before well at some point
I have a gun I'm gonna give it to you
we'll see you might get it first try
don't be like oh that guy just lunged
and kicked you in the face that guy's a
dick yeah
[Music]
uh goob asks what are your favorite guns
pickup so far the big power shot I think
Howard Shaw is smart bomb the smart bomb
I think is like the more I'm like
looking at it and like it'll save your
ass when you're like corner the group of
enemies yeah the power shot is really
great after like a at knocking off those
uh turrets and stuff it's the boss Oh
God way-hey
he immediately went to the pickup like
no dude you don't need that play oh my
god dude
[Music]
stop oh yeah definitely
oh is it
if I can even make it to the boss know
you'll get there oh my god he was
launching that pink [ __ ] so fast
it's hard to pick it up just like in
like the final stage cuz it's like okay
I have to get in the rhythm again right
hey it reminds me of a Nazi Zombies so
we're talk about the other day we're
like you know gets a level like 42 and
it's like dude it's 3:00 a.m. let's go
to bed okay pick up in the morning
before school unpause the game oh yeah
one two three on pause
dad you develop a rhythm no this is
actually extremely hard difficulty yeah
we're pretty good I don't think the
developers can get through this part on
the difficulty we're getting this is
normal yeah
[ __ ] I can't even get through this
use this Wow you know they just use the
dash at the right moments so says the
chat
I mean I feel like I do them at the
right moments but I do emit too many of
the right moments then I can't do it all
right that should help Rosie yeah
it's always the turrets man
oh my god I just destroyed the two
turrets do
[Music]
some of the chat things Peter Brown
would like this game yeah we were shot
we were chatting with him a little bit
yet he seems to think so as well though
he's not lady yet
[Music]
yeah this is normal
Wow you can if any make it the boss know
what it is it's because we turn down the
sound effects we need those cues oh
you're right yeah but I know the chat
really wanted music so
music so good hi there what are you
doing
Ivan stealing
gee
oh my god
oh I saw the power shot I did yeah
too late though
thank God they drop you a shield with
the beating powder
stro yeah so I got it oh my god oh it's
just a multiplier my scores already in
the trash don't worry about that
can you imagine this on hard like who
know like I don't even know what hard is
I just know that with my head would
explode Wow
couldn't -
[Music]
all right
turrets yeah
you know the other thing is to when I
was playing that boss you have to have
those turrets gone
oh he's here your boy yeah he's right
there boy my architecture yard art I
made this game I made you hey I'm the
offer
wow I just got rekt so fast God right
I donno if we're gonna beat this boss
we've got this
[Music]
[Music]
so quick barely saw the boss yeah I know
goob
huh
thank you thank you I want to get out of
here bye have fun
Oh in this bullet hell - triple up
you're good just gotta get rid of that
get rid of that thing
oh no oh okay okay
like how do you how do you get around
that
oh you have no okay - stop doing it so
bad ah
you just stomped on you
Wow oh look I've done nothing to his
help I feel like there is a technique
that we are missing exergy oh my god
it's not fair I'm gonna look up alright
you got there much quicker than I did so
I think if we have any shot of beating
this boss it's gonna be from you that
triple - yeah
weapon uh maybe was eventually luck out
on the right stuff yeah get hit the
triple - get to the weapon up oh he's
already here
hey God well there goes the weapon
weapon up
Oh
oh my god how how are you supposed to do
you know I think I kind of want triple
dish more than a bullet
oh yeah weapon upgrade I feel like the
weapon upgrade helps through this part
yeah but when you get to him yeah I
think you're gonna want this triple - oh
I'm I don't know why Oh shooting a human
already go and brain dead
god
this is insanity
Chris stop by he asked hey what game is
this this is next machina this is house
marks next next game next game Super
Mario Odyssey Super Mario Odyssey
running on the running on the ps4 but
yeah if you played resogun it's similar
the resident thanks for stopping by
those a rad game and if you're not into
the game at least stay for music because
music is hot
it sure is ha
create those forever so how long until
they are scratching the tee from the
architect boss helped me it says the
name up top and Alpha's we made it to
got until her the name spits Goodman I
didn't know Joe I was slipping
all right she'll take that I lost it
immediately whatever another one
Oh shouldn't
[Music]
that's a good tip although I don't know
how how to imply it or how to implement
it he says don't corner yourself with a
- damn close I can see why this music is
high someone I like it yeah this is not
hot tell you what is hot this map she'll
break it
yeah at that triple - I just can now run
it
alright should we give hard a stab right
one more I'm okay now I'm really okay
now I like I just don't like I don't
want this game to win mater fall that
wait no Oh Matt yeah mater fall is house
marks game that they announced a while
back before this game they're working on
which they haven't updated in a while
I'm curious what that will be
[Music]
gube says play for the back you write up
in on
but I think like I was trying to get
away and he closed this one
yeah I imagine we're going to see matter
fall after this drops Navy and e3
but I'm really curious what that is is
they announce it so early I wonder if
it'll still be you or Katy I'm sure we
are Katy but I want to put you a bit
more than like top-down twin-stick
No No well that's quite the explosion
music's gaem and Gatos
Oh sword thanks oh my god
[Music]
oh yeah one more all right I let me do
one more after you then all right
and then we'll give hard a spin all
right we'll see what we won't even
restart on hardwoods or we want to do a
continual just go until which honestly
will probably be like halfway through
first
Oh
ah
those things will mess you up alright so
any triple - though alright where's this
piece of [ __ ] let's go baby
[Music]
distance oh nice threaded the needle
right there oh man no oh
damn
Wow
[Music]
I really don't like this guy you're
doing good no
[Music]
[Applause]
let's uh I think with zero let's try to
prove zero wrong and get to the T that's
a good challenge I'll consider that a
win yeah yeah yeah Adam I tried beating
that it didn't work dammn like a pro
damn oh that's alright it's alright one
life left
nah didn't make it to the tee
[Music]
oh [ __ ] well there goes one my fighter
that triple dash was freaking pee yeah
[Music]
there is I haven't dealt with this there
we go
cross that T baby Oh get away from me
alright I I took down about one
thirtieth of his health I think I can
pick up the slack here I think you're
gonna do it
yep
Oh
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
no get out of that
[Music]
how long time hopefully I can get to the
boss without losing any of them
so much for that
yeah enjoy your home I'll just be here
Oh
draw oh no have to deal with all that
should have been now
all right no guy I really really want to
beat him oh my god I had with with no
there's no way no
jeez this is normal this is normal yeah
normal difficulty I'll try hard for a
little bit after this and then you can
you can switch on the fly can you know
that'd be a bummer I oh that's one round
well I'd love to see this one a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is it's not happening
alright last time
normally
when I die a lot on the stream I'm not
doing very well the chat like eats into
me right there like but with this
everyone's just like holy [ __ ] yeah look
at that looks really hard really like
this is just normal
yeah right
yeah like any other game I feel like we
were in a situation like this I'd be
like no we're gonna do this no matter
how long it takes but it's like no I
don't know if I have eight hours oh if I
knew it was going to be this tough I
would have suggested doing it easy oh
you got the architect and both those
things go around yeah yeah oh you're
good you're good
hey dude Oh
[Music]
shield this is [ __ ] straggler this is
this is being played on PC right now so
there are no ps4 I don't know like what
setting this is what it's pretty a
high-end PC but take a lot to run but I
don't know if there will be ps4
enhancements in the magic
No okay you got one more life left one
more life to scratch the te0 put it oh
[Music]
you're gonna do it
oh you scratch the teeth yeah zero what
uh uncle we did it we beat him good work
everyone
score 40,000 [ __ ] guy worked up a sweat
with that this room gets hot regardless
all right so let's see uh what's a Rhema
about oh you just so really you're in
one spot um we could do hard on arena
and just each do one run on hard see how
that goes okay the sugar fork easy a
slow do forest okay I've never seen a
tilt row okay I control over layout that
simple
uh actually I didn't pick up difficulty
though I wonder if there is no
difficulty arena's probably its own mode
I will then probably cancel laughing oh
they're just exit the gate and I didn't
okay we're good yeah so it looks like
there are no ball so I can go back
scroll down or these so I know but like
the locked ones my Boris redline are
those the other
[Music]
I guess I'm gang are those other worlds
you know everything moves faster
everything's so it looks like they
actually changed up you have four
minutes to get oh they're like
challenges I wonder if that's tight I
would love to do that
hey thirty points too long I don't know
if that oh I see I've got 23 right now
so the more I do these and more points I
get up here
sorry I just bumped Mike and then I can
unlock new ones that's pretty cool that
looks like a fun job to me that kind of
is the progression system do
right alright rip telling this last
thing get that up oh my god it is old
fast oh just
oh man it's way faster huh you move
faster obviously right so that's a plus
you see everyone's shooting that they
all shoot that now so you soon yeah
you're right
everyone shoots [ __ ] Wow word this is
not gonna last long
oh my god
there's no way you got to do wide you
got to do wide patterns or paths here
around that right
I would have been like fighting that
boss with a with a buddy though yeah
good point
baby I've got nothing interesting
oh my gosh get me out of here
I should stop trying to save humans like
it's as much as I want to save the
humans I think I have bigger priorities
like saving a frickin galaxy or from hey
remember we looked at the scoreboard
yeah top leaderboard the guy who like
that's it that was it
do you want to drive yeah all right well
I quit out have you seen start from the
beginning my god watch out revenge
bullets it is hot in here yeah it
generally gets hot but this game if
realizes it seems like wide moving
patterns or what's gonna get you through
this
then like they will punish you of your
tracks
sure
[Music]
what
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
there you go that - triple is Oh
great there goes - triple that was fun
oh my god
philanthropy says this is just a preview
build right what if the boss was not
designed to be defeated because it's a
preview this is a beta build so kind of
a preview it's closed beta build I think
Oh
sneaking another one yeah you ready to
get your time on end it yeah I don't
know I that seemed really tough that
seemed to scale a lot compared to the
second boss but yeah I don't know that
was really tough
wait a second
for a second I felt like I controlled
where I went next with your - what do
you mean maybe I'm just like
overthinking it I mean Oh starters like
the next stage change oh really
I doubt it I just like I felt like I got
I like many certain spots try like
they're I don't know
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Music]
yeah man kinks oh [ __ ] I don't know I
like it
[Music]
tape retrieve something tape one of the
one of the someone in chat says a shame
the stream quality doesn't show off the
amazing voxel stuff yeah it's kind of
I'm sure it's kind of hard to see on it
it does look pretty nice though
I feel like this state this part of the
stage is good you can cover you can kind
of move around corners - holy [ __ ] -
triple there we go baby
no play get out of there though
all right that is something to do with
the shortcut it looks like
good luck
great
Mike my Harding in the chat asked is
this the Dino DNA livestream no great
just threw me off dam and go back to the
menu if Mike's in the chat that means we
should leave yeah all right well uh that
was fun I really like this game it's
really cool that amido feel drained
yeah it did kinda drop style I punch in
the face
thank you guys so much for watching uh
yeah next like makkena next machina
mocking up Jesus Christ that's going to
come out June 20th from yes for peace
yeah ps4 PC just a beta bill
so we'll have to see what the full thing
entails but yeah thank you guys so much
for watching and you have a great
weekend
that's right it's Friday yeah TGIF TJ
does see you guys I'm going bye bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]